i think when you're filming the the
mating does it get to a point where you
just feel like an old perv and you just
kind of think
i'll still stop filming this now because
it's going on for too long
you see your imagination is running away
with you
[Applause]
have you ever seen birds mate i've seen
pigeons mate have you and
how quick it's gone with a lot of
flapping about before they get down to
it
that may be that they are showing off to
one another but the actual copulation
like that really yes it's known as the
cloacal kiss
did you know that kathy well it's only
what i've experienced
[Applause]
thank you for that
one of the one of the uh one of the
things that does make your film so
distinctive
is your voiceovers they elevate things
they give it a kind of an air of of
seriousness and enlightenment
and we have a little uh wildlife clip i
say wildlife there's an animal in it
so if we just look at this little clip
seen this before
it's saturday
if we play that again with a bit of
music a bit of a bit of serious music
and if you do a little voiceover
[Applause]
evening falls on the lush grasslands
of croydon as the humble tortoise
gently mounts his chosen mate
and in a dance as old as time itself
it rears its head and emits
the mighty mating call
[Music]
you